hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast engineering the Humana
poetics system to treat non
hematological disorders presented by dr.
Natalia Gomez Ospina
and Christie jollof lab routes and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
dey's educational web seminars brought
to you by laberd's and sponsored by stem
cell technologies for more information
on our sponsor please visit scam Cellcom
now let's get started I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click the send button if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on that support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or let us know
you're having a problem by using the ask
a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr. Natalia Gomez Ospina assistant
professor of pediatrics genetics and of
pediatrics stem cell transplantation
Stanford University for a complete
biography on dr. gomez Ospina
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. Gomez Ospina you may now begin your
presentation
so Thank You Christy for the
introduction and thank you all for
attending this webinar hopefully you're
all here because you want to learn about
how to entertain your the matter for
Texas eminent you can use this to treat
diseases other than blood disorders so
we'll first review the genetic
modification tools that exist for him I
afford expenses and discuss the pros and
cons of these different tools I will
then discuss how we can use hematocrit
extensions to treat mountain mountain
logical diseases specifically we'll
review studies for efficacy and safety
for one night just in the storage
disease and we'll wrap up with a summary
I like take-home messages but first we
should probably ask why in jail in Iowa
existence I'm here to argue there our
ability to do this precisely and well
has therapeutic implications several
Dominion health so there's the ability
we have a lot of great results injuring
people and carton cell therapy of course
there's an impact on genetic diseases
blood and genetic Hritik and not you
know not illogical and unmet illogical
but I think they could also create
solutions for aging and function the
idea here is to really leverage the fact
that the hematopoietic system is perhaps
the best understood with them and that
it's the one that's really kind of most
fulfilled its promise originated of
medicine unlike any order any other
organ system in the body we have decades
of experience isolating them so why not
try to use all this towards long well I
mentioned that you know we are talking
about the good complications and several
different hope we will quickly remove
the genetically modified mice but
expensive to treat genetic diseases and
the slide is here to convey the message
so genetic diseases are an important
math problem now
Google focusing on states policies
worldwide many of these effective people
are children and a good number of these
children will die or die of genetic
disease according in 2000 there are very
few after the proof therapies that you
can sue or therapy for one time
unscented which is what I'm interested
in developing now we have lotsa
medically modifying we have been
directly modifying a model for example
for decades recombinant replication
efficient retroviral vectors have been
really the most common tools so far for
permanently altering wz cell so they've
been in development for decades there
were systems adverse effects in the
early clinical studies of this led to my
research and safer vectors and
unfortunately they're not by all
therapies that are available sufficient
in a variety of genetic diseases and so
while the webinar is focused primarily
on during the meditation courting of
knowledge that they work the work with
integrating bars still quite relevant
today for Kamata logical and
chronological diseases now despite
tremendous progress and gene additions
and viruses sometimes you really want
precise genitive modifications is this
important import important you can want
to achieve predictable patterns of gene
expression or for targeting specific
alleles you can do that reverses so
genome editing as you all know is a
mechanism to very specifically rewrite
these sequences and typically we think
of genome editing that they a tool to
turn i've known a sequence table shown
here have been correct to a normal
sequence um options miniature correct
but i'm like to say that in fact you
know perhaps more important museum
editing analogous to clued new sequences
Akemi in terms that sometimes can have
even more therapeutic value
now there are several types of genome
editing tools some are included based
and some are not nuclear based at the
core of all nucleated based on geometry
platforms is the ability to create
double-stranded DNA breaks a specific
DNA sequence or genomic location the
differences between all the different
platforms Jordan is going to be based on
the mechanism by which the different
increases are recognizing their target
sequence so engineer nucleus is like the
bigger degrees is employees are these
proteins there are two parts to them one
consists of a customizable CSS ID
binding domain and then they're bound to
end of the place on the crook one in the
nucleus shown here with this or they're
so sensitive places on the left there
being binding domain consists of this
array of sincerity binding domains and
coda to the DNA binding domain is
composed of is repeated advance repeats
derived from transcription activators
not collectors both of these types of
platforms require a lot of protein and
complex synthesis so it has really
limited their widespread adoption but
between these two platforms as the upon
updating the more succinctly
developability purposes are in fact
where the first one to make it to
illusion
an additional problem of the RNA guided
recurrences which are derived from
crystal cast system for research and
therapeutic purposes will be used which
order a modifier better set internal
version of the systems up basically of
two main components
they got RNA some time to believe it is
it's GRE or GRE and CRISPR associated on
the nucleus which is a capo T because of
these and import for assertion and
therapy
most of the cast that are you sort
capellini places direct contribution
california now because of the Arnage
recognition targeting the consequences
only requires changing our names this is
not change so that the person chlorine
has given their wipes for and rapid
adoption launches to modify genius for
her genomes for basic research and
therapeutic application an additional
platform which is a derivation of this
is the base editors patrician sit on the
right these guys make use of a
catalytically inactive chest nine or ten
in the case to target base modifying
ambani such as young Yemenis to the
location so and adenosine Yemenis return
as bad and you need wanting a Tennessee
woman converted science into finding so
the author's should be a couple of
possible in terms of modifying to in
terms of modifying these specific
residues within so there's no double
trying to break from this particular one
which presumably a little bit safer
that's likely to make a cod in the place
amusing and on the other hand you know
you're limited to modify things evening
which is really needed sort of a lot of
things that market for everything so we
begin this editing and general within
the cleared space college might move a
double-stranded break this in this
ultimate trigger a couple of dollars
from brake repair mechanisms either an
automotive in joining abrogated minutes
at an aging J or homology directed
repair of HDR so any two J on the left
here typically does a good job of
repairing the break but the if it's
repair practically regenerates the
target sequences which causes
subsequently donations a break and
repair breaker is there until there's a
mistake that no it's no longer
recognized I get cemented in the
beginning this mistakes tend to manifest
in the form of insurgent issues and we
tend originated here because it's being
built and so lots more decision gives
rights to email on the right we're
showing homology directed repair so you
can do this itself can do this if you
provided with a DNA
plate and the way that emotions the
templates because of complete half
homology through the reasons of TV
around the double-stranded break there's
a little bit harder to do and in the old
adage of the forbidden template but both
repair mechanism can happen
high-efficiency fusions in optimal
conditions so any GJ although it seems
like it's good for breaking things that
actually have therapeutic application so
on the Left I'm showing you an example
of in those generated by one of our
clear critic guides and what I want to
show you is that you agree give any
results in a mixed population of the
lesson this is not hard to control
varies for each guide and the various
personnel so then the NH of the outcomes
are hard to control but nonetheless you
can use this for therapy neon setting
that if you use the image a target
occluding sequence you can prevent
protein expression and what house that
accuses you can use it to target
regulatory elements option three to
decade promoter and has a micro I mean
and the final expected putting
expression can you a person or
activation the payment on the role of
that element Terrence we I'm showing you
like if you can use to guide this within
to create multi species this of course
can mark out a protein but you can
actually use it to restore protein
expression in cases limitations
temperature disruptively cranes when I
created cryptic splice sites this is
also very useful for pathogen expansions
like trying to click I repeat expansion
and interestingly thing also reason to
get to restoring prime so if you if
you're in Dells are mostly one or two or
three nucleotide insertion then vacuum
actually as if acceleration is restored
at wheen point so it hasn't all only
knocking out
therapist HDR
therapeutic HDR again requires a
template you can make more precise
changes so number one year the most
coming approach which is to move it to
create single to change single
nucleotide variant the most efficient we
need doing this but for most generic
think this is useful and diseases where
there's a prevalent come in package
animation an example you to think
something like sickle cell disease but
for most of doing genetic diseases your
teachers are throughout the clean
sequencers you may want to opt for the
number two here we can actually so quiet
the entire coding sequence into the
controller being thousands promoters in
this provided single platform for all
pathogenic variants now nowadays are
limitations to the size of the triplet
complaint so it's possible that you can
fit your entire CD name here and you can
live for option forward like you could
recreate one or several exons and I do
need to be two chakras all and number
three can I'm showing you where you can
an example of integrated sequencer that
contain both schematically sequence and
these are generally placed best
placement amenable find units or however
take harbors these are well cartridges
and into a defensible for the particular
series of targeting on or authority
organism and we'll talk a lot more about
this
HDR can be used to insert post effect
sequences that are response or a lot of
reasoning and basic research they're
used for visualization information
localization but depending on what types
of bigotry on it you're adding that can
actually have and have therapeutic
effects and HDR can use also to make a
very precise solutions
so in addition to producing vision
desire genetic mutations for genome
editing to be therapeutic these
components when the amount musician
targeted to the appropriate cells in the
appropriate organs opinion these are an
actor so there are two approaches for
modifications X 0 which is outside of
the body and directly in the body and
the exterior modification we have to the
modification that self the target cells
might be isolated and available for
transplantation and consequently they
have to be central to the diseases going
after so for the most part the most part
therapies are targeting my voice samples
are done accessible and like I've shown
here on the light there main advantages
of using and makes people approaches
that you have control over to filter the
targeted which you don't just injected
component evil and you have the ability
to perform transplant characterization
of your genie doing anything outcomes
which you know there's still a question
of that have unintended to numerous
modifications or it's better to have an
idea if that's happening before you can
stop the solvent also gives you the
ability to thoroughly examine the degree
of phenotypic collection in the cells
before you can find them so will not
focus on the use of Chris podcast I need
to modify human tonight pretty simple
and a progenitor so I'll try to
alleviate this as a chess pieces on my
mom so as we briefly discussed earlier
depending on where you're intending to
do therapeutic in each EJ or a
therapeutic HDR you must deliver two or
three components in yourself and the
biochemical version of each component
can vary so for example the Catholic
wave commuter is a classmate of viral
genome and I'm on you what protein the
gar I'm a candy desert the plasmid of
rlg Nia module guide system with single
guide system and the repair template can
be this class minimal genome or even a
single stranded DNA molecule so for it
just can see what's going back the most
efficient way of doing this is to
deliver the catheline of the protein
they got its single can modify a guide
in the donor complete after viral genome
and so where it is it your protocol come
from so
first was a seminal paper published by
Alain Delon Rasmus back while they were
in the period up Stamper here they show
that chemically modified our knees and
hands crisper catheline and mana for
example it was particularly the guys
that had chemical modifications that
included it to primal methyl creep and
possible thyroid worked well and the
idea this is guides sure increase
toxicity likely because there was less
activation of meeting these responses to
make it RNA and this resulted in higher
efficiency now the idea of using a need
to deliver the DNA repair complete was
really established by this paper from
Paula cannons lab on here where they
show that the aid they compared
different to your attachment is should
be a big stereotype resulted in the
highest efficiency of home only be
driven genome editing
you
um this light shows your flowchart of a
typical experiment using human Helena
for example beautifully depicted in a
nature protocol article that was
published last year after the cells are
isolated with a some core blood of
problogger
bone marrow the typically the cells were
expanded right now examine for about 14
hours but people are working on methods
to expand the longer period
this usually involves the addition of
bonuses that will preserve stem cell
potential after expansion is over a
modified
using the catheline protein guide the
birth of soybean protein using an
interpolation politic instruction z6
after some time for expression of these
therapeutic correcting learning what you
want to do is analyze HR efficiencies
other reported expression is that's what
you have when using genomic methods will
discuss droplet the joke so after this
we also want a character arts
searching expression with the social
good time to analyze the effects of
modification such and such as effects on
quadrant one organism for gender
differentiation using call information
office and nature species if you're
attempted to design if you're attempting
to design a month up there is important
make sure that new modified poles are so
simple by looking at their solving
capacity using won't come graphics
editing ability as well as the examiner
ability to differentiate into multiple
the matter particle is immunization and
people as well ultimately we want to
assess the efficacy is our cell vehicle
the animal model wanting to me depends
on the processes you are going after so
now we'll show you examples of how 26
planets look like when applied to Nanami
monological multi-systemic disorders
such as a pathogen storage disease the
Greek intro to this diseases so these
are a large group of genetic conditions
that results from deficiencies the
resulting nutrition aggression and then
or proteins in general
lysosomes are important centers for
catabolism themselves there and charge
of degrading and recycling
macromolecules take your imaginative
certain that career function is pretty
essential for emotional types so when
there's nitrogen is a function that can
affect a lot of different pathogens they
manifest as problems and more important
systems cells in the brain however are
exquisitely acceptable to my changes
from controllability on for the majority
of this diseases has an illogical
involvement so many of these J's
involved analyses and code for life
isn't events that are responsible for
degrading have a light on all of them
are enzyme some of them are membrane
proteins now many of these enzymes are
memories secreted into the extracellular
space they are modified with the manual
plastic residues which I'm showing you
here red bump and they can be
internalized by any cell that has a
menace across the receptor so what this
means is that a cell with enzymatic
activity can effectively correct
yourself without a manic activity and
this is a property that is in which
cross correction is the basis all the
therapies that have been designed for
this diseases so a corollary to the
property of course correction is that
the you can complicate enzymatic
activity and some and Van Ginkel in the
body and that should treat other organ
systems that are not directly that
you're not directly targeting or
correcting your genome editing
approaches for example so our goal here
is to use the modified system to really
call correct or organ so a canonical LSD
is the disease called
mucopolysaccharides of the type one I
read it
abbreviated if SP is one it's also known
at hurler syndrome
does the things that you can see from
the table affect multiple organs
including the brain controller like many
genetic diseases that are due to either
my problems or degrees of symptoms
depending on how much residual activity
Novation past so patients with severe
disease have progressive cognitive
impairment which without treatment it's
fatal on the first decade of life
patients that have some residual
activity have less cognitive issues at
the bottom line on time binding the
residual America because if you can
different eco patients or severe
patients have some right now are between
zero and point two percent over
scheduled activity and patients with a
10-year disease have about with a median
of point percent in that can be so you
can see that a very little very little
enzyme because I teach difference in the
natural history of disease and this is
important to know when you're designing
a therapy because it tells you that's
been necessary the realistic there is
therapeutic successful you're trying to
which means that for the disease is not
hundred percent nineteen fifty percent
but you know a few percent you make a
big difference so you might think this
disease is extremely rare why would I
care about care about that it actually
is this is a disease that um it's not
part of several needles green program in
the in several states across the United
States so the states are normally
including my home state of California
so this is news is the result of
announcing absent maximum of enzyme
called ideal on today's operated IDU a
and without this enzyme like causing the
glycans on the negative gag to make
throughout the body
this results in this progressive with
the systemic disease patients with this
disease had currently two treatment
options and then resistant therapy or
ERP is the intravenous deliverable
common in enzyme it's expensive requires
chronic administration doesn't treat the
brain because it isn't competent barrier
it is also never the treating zone the
other option is allergen a simple
transplantation on a low H ACP
this has been shown to arrest and
prevent cognitive decline in children
but because an allogeneic transplant
involve the transfer means it's an one
person to another it can have can
morbidity and mortality in so because of
that nearly reserved it for children
that have severe severe disease data
before they address to them that have
normal cognitive evaluation the time to
find them so that's the risk work well
under thinking so how does a Hamada for
example consultation work so and this is
easy works better than your teen because
number one it provides it constantly the
more the enzyme and the most important
because the bone marrow generates the
monocytes and after that tissue
macrophages that can migrating to
receive new tissues like liver spleen
great one to deliver your therapeutic
protein in this case love being a
selection event locally this my Croatian
is trigger impaired by the conditions
regular username advocacy consultation
but also by the disease process that
causes the connection can be more
handsome self itself
so given some of the facts that I've
given you
art art will be think so
you can see that on there is a very
important role for these cells and the
therapeutic benefit of a cheesy cheese
intriguing on the organ and so it from
the fact that giving you make sense to
propose the treatment for this disease
and even some of these other diseases
can be improved by establishing an
apologist consultation of humility
generated and my point exten so the
general idea is for isolate the
patient's own medical ethics and within
ourselves which are positive for this
markridge t34 that you modify the mixed
in role or using crystal cap 9 instead
of targeting individual mutations or
even individual genes we decided to
target enzyme expression cassette into a
safe harbor as we described earlier I
referred to as a targeted to magician
approach we have the other discoveries
of transformers occupations will they
really constitute bloody also
macrophages that will treat other organs
now I wanted to talk a little bit about
the safe harbor idea so again it's a
little bit that doesn't happen it's
essential functions in the moment of
development for health in this example
we've picture of five
we consider this a safe harbor because
there are millions of people in the
world that have delusions in this genes
are to being particularly European
population more than 10% of them join
express this protein and this
observation on measurable it was noted
that patients who were didn't expect
that you're higher also to HIV infection
so we know we don't need this there are
several advantages to using a safe
harbor one is obvious being you don't
have to design your therapy for every
mutation because patients usually have a
different mutation so you don't have to
redesign the therapy every time the
second thing is that in this particular
diseases you know that you're kind of
using the blood to express an
environment normal levels of expression
or masked obsession so you want to drive
Supra androgynous expression you know
that by using this genetic approach the
other thing is you have a clean
sequencing farther engineer to enhance
therapy and I said you can think of some
of the others how to do that most
importantly safe harbor waiting and
versatile and easily adaptable to other
analysts and usually even other other
situations where you want to like to
secrete any more dedicated coaching so
in the next few slides we'll go through
these experiments which comes to
personal comfort studies showing that
the human gene many mean it just pcs to
express hydraulics can't correct
symptoms multiple organs and creates one
so we use a as we described earlier we
use the aren't pls a system path my
personal guide and six our guide turkish
exercise locus and I'm showing you here
connect I systemic of a generic template
you can see that in the census you can
vary the promoter you can get eaten very
the template and you can add a
collectible or or reporter it's a
helpful for you
and so how do you measure target
integration human mind court expenses
so the first step towards achieving high
efficiencies of modification in the cell
team starts with having a guy that has
good efficiency for this particular
guide you can see that in cells right
from kornblatt attrition right here
purple veterans you get either 85% of
75% of the film really will become have
in bills a memory measuring bill using
Sanger sequences and then average
because this convoluted using freely
available software online I'm giving you
an example here on this slide you can
see from the sequences and also from the
pictogram of the most common known to
the system is a single nucleotide
insertion and you keep the exact public
you have our expression that the ad
additionally the guide with the
catheline organism Adam P decreases the
expression in the future hi guys so we
are knocking it out when we do this this
process you can measure the frequency of
targeting duration by looking at
reporter expression in this cave and
using yellow fluorescent protein you can
see three expression cassettes here two
of them have a reporter one of them
governs and one of them is created by a
very strong viral promoter fffe and the
other one is strong because digital
period coming up okay
you can measure your reporter for uses
of course important for photometry with
a porous email I ask that you see that
with strong women than P key K and you
can basically measure how many folds now
expressing your protein so you can see
that the core blood in general we gather
average my patients very high person
MOBA cells which is not bad 20 something
percent healthy person corporeal blonde
now if you if you remove your reporter
and you're cutting your integrated cuz
it's smaller your efficiencies can go
higher so this is the efficiencies
really depend on the insert size and if
we've a beautifully among the good
medication rates in it and the new 30
percent
now you can measure integrations more
directly by looking at the look itself
here I'm showing the use of droplet did
you open our two accomplices there are
of course all the ways to do this on so
to do do the PCR you need a purse
approach that works at the reference
could be anywhere else in genome but we
prefer to place it in chromosome another
probe assay that will read only your
integrated version of your real I'm not
sure very specific to what you wanted
we're looking have primers inside and
outside homology on and that's how we
make sure that replicated integrated the
acid can validate it so here we
validated it with the DNA from the
calling that have anyone will modify to
know the answer it works well have 2.5
and conservative and use this to measure
the percentages as modified alleles in
April so that allows you to confirm that
you're doing with the Intendant
integration not randomization genotyping
of colonies derive Princeton yourself
which is something you can Union HSBC is
a great way to quantify some one of the
key traits we needed to have a reporter
for modification
and also it allows you to quantify rates
of mana environment integration so in
this particular example not integrating
wheels are bigger 1.1 KB and integrated
wheels show at lower bands so if you
have two bands you're modifying one or
two alleles Oman on the complications
and its momentum operator qualification
so let's talk about you know how to
write a check for expression of these
areas of protonated particular example
we keep our expression how the lysosomal
anyone so here you can see that we look
at this OGS installed to have based on
report expression 5p high low or
negative we are assuming that the last
attack cells are the ones that have to
integrate Quebec and we can demonstrate
that by showing the details you can't
see culture for a very long time and
they will always Express the reporter
and the enzyme because precise it's
integrated in the DNA now if you
compared the modified cells with an
modified cells you can see their cells
that are expressed by a drawn based
region that idea specific promoter have
several hundred fold more enzyme
expression and some cells that express
that were modified with a PDK kiss
aspects place between 25 and 50 51 1 so
the enzyme can be measure in my face but
as I'm entering for these are normally
secreted when we measure a culture in
Lunia so we are absolutely meant to do
we're expressing super a physiological
eligible in them as I mentioned to you
earlier at Central Conference concept of
about the idea of using interesting
agency T to treat other audiences that
the progeny in particularly modified
macrophages
will continue to express stable super
physiological levels of an assignments
or the data components of that is okay
so you can take your HSBC's and portion
and differentiation in vitro with the
right prior crimes and even after
differentiation we continue to express
multimap welcome to end by
now they make concern about the use a
nucleobase genome editing platforms
records the purposes possibility of
creating Dutchman
Nene breaks it into these guys come
referred to as off target site so there
are a variety of ways to measure you
know this genotoxicity and result
generally they're divided between bias
meaning by and chromatic we predicted or
unbiased approaches so what I'm showing
you here is an example of a
bioinformatics guided approach means
that bioinformatics tool are called
cause men to predict alternate activity
based on sequence similarity so it
predicted 67 sites
and then you go and sequence them simply
to see there are modifications in the
site so when standard cast 9 while
snitches join the cabin while type you
see for sites that have off-target
activity they're involved in the
protection for next-gen sequencing which
is come on there involve the background
they repeated in various experiments so
for out of 67 you can see that they're
very very low levels of off target
activity is point 5 but most important
when you switch the cast line to a
version that has a mutation than half
provides us with higher fidelity the go
away now there are as I mentioned before
they're more and by the way G my please
look at this tool is actively developed
like average the monster is a new one
that I list some of these tools though
probably not comprehend there's an
account classifying between the neutral
and locus approaches so it's another way
to set off target activity in so if
you're trying to define a long term
hopefully one-time therapy you watch
Carter than long term popular time
selling to you want to make sure that
after the modifications is helps
attaining that into alchemy and and
differentiate into multiple images the
schematic is supposed to remind you of
the structure that not a kind
compartment remember there's a bum now
the purple stem cell that can soften you
and also give rise to progenitors which
will give rise to all these different
cells in the bone marrow to a series of
steps and gradual process of commitment
differentiation the question of
sovereign rule is typically addressed by
checking of the cells that have
undergone them and you can wrap it
really rapid studies if you are using
human cells in your have to you have to
compromise my study because we used not
skip compromise on the readability
here which meant the cells were selected
based on recorded expressions
and I'm looking at the attorney data
from primary Latin studies so after 16
weeks 15 16 weeks you looked at the
millisiemens college enrollment in other
organ you can see that yourself yourself
there and the closer engrafted are if
you engrafted yp+ saws of the end their
life be positive confirming that because
in fact modified you can also notice
that there isn't increasing wrapping
potential it's it's all compounded comes
in another thing we think but this is
because there are fewer
repopulating clones and that population
this is based on observations that HR
less efficient so they're essentially
the truth stencil so also in the mice
you would be able to look at myself I'm
not sure about data but this experiments
also allowed to show that there is a
huge differentiation that can tell you
that themselves differentiate
a precise what has the most important is
to show me the efficacy of yourself in
the standard way of doing this is using
animal models during a human cells is
great because they're ultimately your
target pulses this adds significant
limitation for testing advocates and
animal models as you have to contend
with the potential of the rejection of
the cells so to get around this for this
particular example we ought to you can
mouse model the disease that was capable
in recognizance and it's also used
CRISPR to knocking at the vir human
mutation into energy mouse embryos so so
and to make a long story short these
animals replicate the disease
fortunately for us the same as females
predicted plantations and I had been
dumped it is important keeping me to
compass of mine considered a lack is an
activity exists in a bag the general
visual indications that that you expect
so when you conference our modify human
modified cells in both CRISPR cells for
example that didn't have a cut to the
marker you can see for their positive
impact on the magnetic markers so on the
right you can see that enzymes were
constituted to make intense red top's
the blue dots primarily in the liver
going to get to brown you get more than
normal in somatic excluding and this
results in an overall because in gag
storage which measure in the urinary
exclusion of gags and some tissues Edna
burns clean the GAC short is completely
reversed in the brain and don't see the
same types of differences and we'll come
back to this
consistent with the back industry the
transportation will improve all
phenotypic abnormalities so
there's results an improvement in a
skeletal phenotype when were there you
can find results in bulk or sorted
especially in the fiddling system we've
seen improvements in neuronal parameters
and this grass here they want to compare
so the red bars with the rate of lives
the blue lines you can see the
transplanted line have improved planting
locomotion activity they can improve
short-term memory they can basically
there so it is positively positively
something the control another person so
I just want to summarize here that you
know so we have humanistic youth can be
in here with good efficiencies I showed
you an example of using feature five
they probably look a particularly we're
coming towards its large expression
process what she's really pretty well we
show you that the cells remain
themselves after modification that we
preserve the homecoming population look
at leadership at your potential and
actually details are capable of
improving we type in the mouse and not
be not illogical these new clients go to
code and grain as well as backing up a
few types of liver and spleen
you
so we describe this is a potential
platform to her life so my advice
passage can be more Amendment to be say
well it's actually the platform for push
the creatable therapy protein so
technically we could try to go think
about using this for other nice MLM
science you know there's more than 50 of
these diseases but I wanted to give you
another example so in the example that I
described we use constitutive promoters
that we engage every cell including the
heme I placed importance on expression
and we knew that because they didn't
really affecting the enzyme substance
doesn't affect the Hinata for example
the progenitors but this was a way to
maximize all protein expression there
might be cases where this is not what
you want doing I want to restricted to
certain types of cells so here I'm sure
an example of another enzyme called
glucose cerebroside a's in which that
expressing an order the compartments
could affect in grafton so we restricted
expression to the stuff that we really
care about which is a modified set
macrophages especially in the disease
that cause that is the result of glucose
or decided absence which is Gaucher
disease so you can see that this safe
harbor strategy can be quite flexible
you have one therapy for all your
patients or limitations as in addition
you can use this tissue lineage-specific
promoters to make the system even more
customizable so i think now it's time to
wrap up down here what i think are the
most important take-home messages
therapeutic and HJ can be used to
decrease or increase expression of kinds
of proteins therapeutic HDR allows you
to precisely next notification and the
ability synthesizes new coding sequences
and regulatory systems which which
really opens up more therapeutic options
the safe harbor which is flexible
platform for the expression of their
created protein from reaction that I'm
not opposed to think can deliver is
deadly equipment to other organs the
primary effector cells we know or the
tissue delivery are the month as
macrophages and
such strategies remove optimal to
secrete the protein
and now I would like to open it up for
questions
Thank You dr. Gomez Ospina for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now to our audience if you have
a question you would like to ask if you
haven't already done it please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many questions as
we have time for now let's get started
ok dr. Gomez's fina let's start with
this first question can you talk about
how you narrow down your culture
conditions for editing the cd34 positive
self
well that's a great question because we
have been using culture conditions have
been reported in the literature for a
while and to be honest a lot of the
people who are doing this haven't really
thought very carefully about you know
whether we're really using the best
conditions possible so you know they are
they are out there different options for
that so the bottom line is know very
little about how to culture themselves
also the body and so people are working
on different types of cultures whether
to keep the meat ascetic or change it
continuously there's a set of cytokines
that everybody uses but nobody really
understands doses we know that we're
certainly adding too much of certain
cytokines with the ADF of hoping to
expand these cells outside of the body
they are actually a bunch of new small
molecules and even cytokines that are
being added to these cultures so to make
a sort of a long answer short we've done
very little optimization and I think
there's a lot to be done so we're
basically using cultural conditions that
have been described for a while
thank you no next question what are some
barriers you see in moving crisper based
cell therapies from the lab to the
clinic
so there's an incredibly complex
question and we could talk for a long
time about this I think a big barrier
for all kinds of therapies whether
they're CRISPR based or cell based or
gene theory basa the biggest error
really is financial incentives so you
know for rare diseases we used to they
were not that long ago we have plenty of
diseases for which there were no
experimental therapy so right now
they're actually competing therapies
which a lot of them you know are viral
based and and some are easier to deliver
and some have been in developing and
development for a longer time so it's
sometimes hard to find money to work on
a therapy because you have all these
other therapies but you know to be more
precise you know there is a issue the
challenges are in sort of at the level
of preclinical research so when you're
doing your research and animals one is
assess an efficacy meaning you know
there's this are you you are you really
using the suitable animal model and that
really applies to almost any therapy but
this is particularly tricky when you're
trying to engineer human cells and so
you have very little options in terms of
testing testing them in an animal model
perhaps more importantly really is the
safety aspect of assessing the
specificity of these genome editing
technologies this is a space that's kind
of changing very quickly in terms of
tools that are available and it's also
kind of unclear what the regulatory
agencies are really requesting that you
really have to show them in order for
them to be convinced that your approach
it's really safe and the the safety is
not just about the genotoxicity of
making double-stranded breaks where you
don't want them but it also you know
they a very important problem for
everyone that is trying to replace
expression of genes or proteins that
we're not in the body before is a imogen
immunogenicity issue that either from
your vectors but very specifically also
from our for our CRISPR editing tools so
yeah a lot of challenges
thank you well our np+ a a v6 EP effect
HS PC viability
so we know that he alone will decrease
the cornered industry of HSBC so if so
AV itself has an effect on on Kanchana
city it's true and and and so we are
subjecting themselves to a complex
process also you know electroporation
also triggers a variety of you know
activates a bunch of signaling pathways
as well so it does
thank you our next question have you
tested the effects of static versus
continuous flow bioreactor type cultures
ah we haven't we would like to I think
that's an important question what
happens with these cultures particularly
progenitor cells can be expressing
cytokines that may be inducing
differentiation or compromising you know
stemness so I think that it's very
likely that you know better sort of
continuous flow systems will would have
positive effects on maintaining stem as
in these cultures
the next question
so the half-life of modified stem cells
is how long and how do they generate
regenerate
so if we're talking about hematite
extend cell and progenitor cells I mean
they have like really depends on how you
work where you're testing them right
we've kept them in vitro for for a
really long time months in the mice you
could do the serial transplantation
experiments that are really about trying
to capture this true stem cells that are
capable self-renewing for a long time so
you do a first experiment that varies
between four and five months you take
the cells and you put them in another
mice you wait another four and five
months and you can do it again so these
Co transplantation experiments we've
done and we're done them for 40 months
but some people even do an additional
render transplantation
in human that we expect these cells
should to last forever if they're true
stem cells and that's the whole point of
trying to really do the best that you
can to confirm that these cells or stem
cells
go miss Tina have you had any issues
acquiring a high enough titer of a a v6
to be used as a donor template
um enough tighter no I mean we've you
know there are we we have conditions
where there's definitely too much too
much a V on the cells that it becomes so
usually when we start an experiment and
try to design a new donor template we do
a tritation experiment where we kind of
find the point where we maximize editing
efficiency and sort of kind of find a
sweet spot with the effects on viability
and so what I would say is generally
getting enough titer is not the problem
you know there are a lot of other issues
with how much a V will actually you know
get liberated from the endosomes and
content and how that template will
actually be used for a charge so ever
every locus is different and we find
that it we really haven't found a really
good way to predict which ones will have
really good efficiencies to with the to
do the HDR part of the repair that
requires it simply and so we don't
really know what goes into that
now we have some great questions coming
in and we may not have time to get to
all of them so I do want to remind our
audience that those questions we do not
have time to get to today and those that
are submitted during our on-demand
period will be answered via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration okay but let's keep trying
to go through our QA here dr. Gomez's
vena can you share with us what the
potential side effects of gene therapy
using gene editing are
so I guess I'd the one issue that
everyone talks about is the possibility
of creating a change somewhere in the
genome that you didn't and usually most
people are worried about you know
disrupting you know you know activating
protocol Algonquin genes or disrupting
tumor suppressor genes that could lead
to two to merge ethnicity in the future
this is particularly important in HSBC's
or the protocol that I've described to
you because you really are modifying a
cell population and so well then that's
all true then those millions of cells
are you potentially transmitted in the
patient it could be a few clones that
could have those changes so so that is
sort of theoretically a real possibility
let me remind you that people you know
people have using lentiviruses which
integrate randomly or sort of randomly
into genomes and those have actually
made it into people so you know there
are always risks and and benefits to be
weighted I think the other issue that
it's we haven't paid enough attention to
event mentioned earlier is the issue of
immunogenicity so the nice thing about
doing this thing's XP Ville is that you
if you let's say there are there's data
now showing that you could be discussed
nine proteins come from from bacteria
that are very common in people and we
may have in two bodies and we have 2010
stone so do netic vivo can probably ever
do some likelihood that you're going to
respond to that it's that could be a
patient problem if you're trying to use
this in vivo but also there could be
immunogenicity to the you know to the
protein itself you know so if you're
trying to replace a protein that a
patient with a genetic disease didn't
have they may recognize it as foreign
so it's something else to think about
those are two potential pit bulls I'd
I'm sure there are more very good thank
you now Mon well Leonetti has a paper in
bio archive that showed that HDR may not
be as accurate as it may be showing that
parts of large inserts can be new
stated in different types of donors like
plasmids SSI vienna's I'm teaching our
products have you noticed anything like
that with a a v6 donor I haven't looked
too much into that to be honest but I
know that other people have noticed
those changes they're rare I mean the
majority of the times you get the
appropriate change but yeah you can have
errors and it's interesting because
there's different types of cells have
different repair mechanisms when you do
this kind of work in embryonic stem
cells or even embryos you get surprising
you know very different types of repair
so yeah and I think that you know the
tools that we have so far which we're
just kind of focused on the one little
area that we're trying to to change are
really not allowing us to see the
entirety of the changes that were that
we're making
now do you think there is an ideal level
of activity for the enzyme from the
modified cells or should we restrict
this to avoid other target defects
so for each therapy protein or enzyme
really
it varies and I think you need to sort
of kind of get an idea of what that is
from the literature or from experimental
II so some levels so for the example
that I showed you with this enzyme
Majorana days we knew that high levels
we're okay because people had been had
overexpressed it hugely and that and
mouth cells and they there was no
problems with in grassman and
differentiation there are other enzymes
where you probably want to restrict the
activities so as I showed you using
different promoters allows you to kind
of play with that a little bit so that
that's in terms of like regulating the
levels of a therapeutic protein what
other levels of hurting themselves in
terms of regulating you know the actual
editing event that's that's an
interesting question we're not at the
point where we're getting so much
editing that we are wanting to like have
less of it I think for every if you're
trying to design if you're starting an
approach with a genome with a nucleus
based platform what you need to do
really early on is to especially if
you're using CRISPR cap 9 is to focus on
your find a good guy that gives you good
efficiencies and characterize the
off-target effects of that off that
guide to the best of your ability is
early on and process so you don't need
or find out that it that particular guy
has you know many up target sides and so
it's something you should try to do
early on
thank you we're going to try to squeeze
in just a few more questions what
approach in vivo versus ex vivo would be
suitable for correcting single based
notation in sickle-cell disease in human
subjects
so I'm most aware of ex-vivo approaches
to correct successful disease and humans
using exactly the same protocol that I
described on guide to the HTTP gene a
calculating protein actually you know
now using higher fidelity versions of
the cache line and using a v6 to to the
rezidentura template so that's that's a
reading development I mean there are
different variations of this approach
and that people may not be you say b6
people are using could be using single
strand of DNA Allah goes so I'm only
aware of the ex vivo approaches you know
theoretically you could try to do it in
vivo I'm not sure how those efficiencies
would compare but again the nice thing
about doing the succeed was it allows
you to kind of really characterize some
of these concerning issues that we're
talking about like you know off target
activity etcetera
and then right now before you actually
deliver the problem to the patient got
it
our next question what about the
delivery system effect well I think we
started talking about that a little bit
earlier so we know we are putting
yourself through a lot it involves you
know these are you know these are GPC so
some of these progenitors are sort of
within they are about to be immune cells
some of them have pretty aggressive
immune recognition systems and so we're
exposing them to catheline is posing
them to an RNA we exposing them to
electroporation and we exposing them to
AV so I first mean you know so you can
you can measure gene expression changes
in the past and people started doing
these experiments that we're using other
plasmids or naked RNA or the cap 9 was
deliver as an mRNA or as a plasmid and
what we know is that delivering as
protein and a modified guide really
decreases a lot of those effects but
there are some and and then there's like
as we discussed earlier the AV has
effects on VHS PCs as well
thank you can we use the HS pcs as a
therapy for inflammation of
neurodegenerative disorder I think so I
think it were I think so and encouraging
people recently I don't remember it was
very recent but I think yeah there's no
I think there's good evidence to think
that that would be possible
thank you and dr. Gomez was seen over
not to wrap with this final question
here how can we make sure that the cells
that we save after re injection into
patients especially because these cells
were in vitro expanded
chuckling make sure that the cells are
saved are saved
yes after reinjection and so I mean if I
understand this question correctly
so normally you know when you these
earlier trials will probably require
that you have a backup temple of the
patient cells that are modified to be
able to rescue in case you know the
cells don't work I'm not sure that's
where the question is going but yeah so
you know the for for patients
specifically they'll probably a
requirement to have a backup of
unmodified cells but you can use in case
that your therapy doesn't work
very good and if we didn't answer that
question correctly please feel free to
submit that question again Amon and
we'll try to answer your question more
correctly I want to thank all of our
attendees who submitted their questions
we had a great Q&A session today but I
really want to thank dr. Gomez's bina
for her time today and her important
research we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsors stem cell
technologies for underwriting today's
educational webcast as a reminder to our
audience those questions we didn't
excuse me those questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during our on-demand period will be
addressed via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
now this webcast can be viewed on demand
and labyrinth will alert you via email
when it is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day
Thank You dr. Gomez's FINA for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of our webinar now to our audience if
you have a question you would like to
ask if you haven't already done it
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
questions as we have time for now let's
get started okay dr. Gomez's FINA let's
start with this first question can you
talk about how you narrow down your
culture conditions for editing the cd34
positive cells
well that's that's a great question
because we have been using culture
conditions have been reported in the
literature for a while and to be honest
a lot of the people who are doing this
haven't really thought very carefully
about you know whether we're really
using the best conditions possible so
you know they are they are out there
different options for that so the bottom
line is know very little about how to
culture this house outside and body and
so people are working on different types
of cultures whether to keep the meat
ascetic or change it continuously
there's a set of cytokines that
everybody uses but nobody really
understands the doses we know that we're
certainly adding too much of certain
cytokines with the ad of hoping to
expand these cells outside of the body
they are actually a bunch of new small
molecules and even cytokines that are
being added to these cultures so to make
a sort of a long answer short we've done
very little optimization and I think
there's a lot to be done so we're
basically using cultural conditions that
have been described for a while
thank you now next question what are
some barriers you see in moving crisper
based cell therapies from the lab to the
clinic
so there's an incredibly complex
question and we could talk for a long
time about this I think a big barrier
for all kinds of therapies whether
they're CRISPR based or cell based or
gene theory baselet the biggest error
really is financial incentives so you
know for rare diseases we used to they
were not that long ago we had plenty of
diseases for which there were no
experimental therapy so right now they
are actually competing therapies which a
lot of them you know are viral based and
and and some are easier to deliver and
some have been in developing and
development for a longer time so it's
sometimes hard to find money to work on
a therapy because you have all these
other therapies but you know to be more
precise you know there is a issue the
challenges are in sort of at the level
of preclinical research so when you're
doing your research and animals one is
assessing ethic si meaning you know
there's this are you you are you really
using the suitable animal model and that
really applies to almost any therapy but
this is particularly tricky when you're
trying to engineer human cells and so
you have very little options in terms of
testing testing them in an animal model
perhaps more importantly really is a
safety aspect of assessing the
specificity of these genome editing
technologies this is a space that's kind
of changing very quickly in terms of
tools that are available and it's also
kind of unclear what the regulatory
agencies are really requesting that you
really have to show them in order for
them to be convinced that your approach
it's really safe and the the safety is
not just about the genotoxicity of
making double-stranded breaks where you
don't want them but it also you know
they a very important problem for
everyone that is trying to replace
expression of genes or proteins that
were not in the body before is the
Inogen immunogenicity issue that either
from your vectors by very specifically
also from our for our CRISPR editing
tools so yeah a lot of challenges
thank you well our np+ a a v6 EP effect
HS PC viability
so we know that AV alone will decrease
the cloner tenacity of the HSBC so if so
AV itself has an effect on on Kanchana
City it's true and and and so we are
subjecting these cells to a complex
process also you know electroporation
also triggers a variety of you know
activates a bunch of signaling pathways
as well so it does
thank you our next question have you
tested the effects of static versus
continuous flow bioreactor type cultures
ah we haven't we would like to I think
that's an important question what
happens with these cultures particularly
progenitor cells can be expressing
cytokines that may be inducing
differentiation or compromising you know
stemness so I think that it's very
likely that you know better sort of
continuous flow assistance will would
have positive effects on maintaining
stem as in these cultures
the next question so the half-life of
modified stem cells is how long and how
do they generate regenerate
so if we're talking about pegmatitic
stem cell and progenitor cells I mean
they have like really depends on how you
work where you're testing them right
we've kept them and be true for for a
really long time months in the mice you
could do the serial transplantation
experiments that are really about trying
to capture this true stem cells that are
capable self-renewing for a long time so
you do a first experiment that varies
between four and five months you take
the cells and you put them in another
mice you wait another four and five
months and you can do it again so these
zero transplantation experiments we've
done and we're done them for 40 months
but some people even do an additional
render transplantation
in human that we expect these cells
should to last forever if they're true
stem cells and that's the whole point of
trying to really do the best that you
can to confirm that the cells are stem
cells
Gomez's FINA have you had any issues
acquiring a high enough titer of a a v6
to be used as a donor template
um enough tighter no I mean we've you
know there are we we have conditions
where there's definitely too much too
much a V on the cells that it becomes so
usually when we start an experiment and
try to design a new donor template we do
a tritation experiment where we kind of
find the point where we maximize editing
efficiency when and sort of kind of find
a sweet spot with the effects on
viability and so what I would say is
generally getting enough titer is not
the problem you know there are a lot of
other issues with how much a V will
actually you know get liberated from the
endosomes and content and how that
template will actually be used for a
charge so ever every locus is different
and we find that it we really haven't
found a really good way to predict which
ones will have really good efficiencies
to with the to do the HDR part of the
repair that requires it's plate and so
we don't really know what goes into that
q now we have some great questions
coming in and we may not have time to
get to all of them so I do want to
remind our audience that those questions
we do not have time to get to today and
those that are submitted during our
on-demand period will be answered via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration okay but let's keep
trying to go through our key way here um
dr. Gomez's Nina can you share with us
what the potential side-effects of gene
therapy using gene editing are
so I guess I'd the one issue that
everyone talk for that is the
possibility of creating a change
somewhere in the genome that you didn't
and usually most people are worried
about you know disrupting you know you
know activating protocol Algonquin genes
or disrupting tumor suppressor genes
that could lead to two to merge
ethnicity in the future this is
particularly important and it just B C's
or the protocol that I've described to
you because you really are modifying a
cell population and so within that cells
within those millions of cells that you
potentially transmitting to the patient
that could be a few clones that could
have those changes so so that is sort of
theoretically a real possibility let me
remind you that people you know people
have using lentiviruses which integrate
randomly or so randomly into genomes and
those have actually made it into people
so you know they're always risks and and
benefits to be weighted I think the
other issue that it's we haven't paid
enough attention to as I mentioned
earlier is the issue of immunogenicity
so the nice thing about doing this
thing's ex-people
is that you if you would say there are
there's data now showing that you could
be discussed nine proteins come from
from bacteria that are very common in
people and we may have antibodies and we
have T cell system so do netic vivo can
probably reduce the likelihood that
you're going to respond to that it's
that Mercer could be a potential problem
if you're trying to use this in vivo but
also there could be immunogenicity to
the you know to the protein itself you
know so if you're trying to replace a
protein that a patient with a genetic
disease didn't have they may recognize
there's foreign so it's something else
to think about those are two potential
pitfalls I'm sure there are more very
good thank you
now Manuel Leonetti has a paper in bio
archive that showed that HDR may not be
as accurate as it may be showing that
parts of large inserts can be
mutated in different types of donors
like plasmids SS lVN's and PCR products
have you noticed anything like that with
a a v6 donor I haven't looked too much
into that to be honest but I know that
other people have noticed those changes
they're rare I mean the majority of the
times you get the appropriate change but
yeah you can have errors and it's
interesting because there's different
types of cells have just different
repair mechanisms when you do this kind
of work and embryonic stem cells or even
embryos you get surprising you know very
different types of repair so yeah and I
think that you know the tools that we
have so far which we're just kind of
focused on the one little area that
we're trying to to change are really not
allowing us to see the entirety of the
changes that were that we're making
now do you think there is an ideal level
of activity for the enzyme from the
modified cells or should we restrict
this to avoid other off-target effects
so for each therapy protein or enzyme
really
it varies and I think you need to sort
of kind of get an idea of what that is
from the literature or from
experimentally so some levels so for the
example that I showed you with this
enzyme Majorana days we knew that high
levels we're okay because people had
been had overexpressed it hugely and
that and mouth cells and they there was
no problems with in grassman and
differentiation there are other enzymes
where you probably want to restrict
activity so as I showed you using
different promoters allows you to kind
of play with that a little bit so that
that's in terms of like regulating the
levels of the therapeutic protein what
other levels of hurting themselves in
terms of regulating you know the actual
editing events that's that's an
interesting question we're not at the
point where we're getting so much
editing that we are wanting to like have
less of it I think for every if you're
trying to design if you're starting an
approach with a genome with a nucleus
based platform what you need to do
really early on is to especially if
you're using CRISPR calf sign is to
focus on your find a good guy that gives
you good efficiencies and characterize
the off-target effects of that off that
guide to the best of your ability is
early on in the process so you don't
need or find out that it that particular
guy has you know many up target sides
and so it's something you should try to
do early on
thank you we're going to try to squeeze
in just a few more questions what
approach in vivo versus ex vivo would be
suitable for correcting single based
notation in sickle-cell disease in human
subjects
so I'm most aware of ex-vivo approaches
to correct pixel disease and humans
using exactly the same protocol that I
described a guide to be HBB gene a Cal
sign protein actually you know now using
higher fidelity versions of the cache
line and using a v6 to to the resident
work template so that's that's a reading
development I mean there are different
variations of this approach and that
people may not be used 86 people are
using could be using single stranded DNA
oligos so I'm only aware of the ex vivo
approaches you know theoretically you
could try to do it in vivo I'm not sure
how those efficiencies would compare but
again the nice thing about doing the
sixy was it allows you to kind of really
characterize some of these concerning
issues that we're talking about like you
know off target activity etcetera
and done right now before you actually
deliver the problem to the patient got
it
our next question what about the
delivery system effect well I think we
started talking about that a little bit
earlier so we know we are putting
yourself through a lot it involves you
know these are you know these are T CPC
so some of these progenitors are sort of
within they are about to be immune cells
some of them have pretty aggressive
immune recognition systems and so we're
exposing them to catheline with posing
them to an RNA we closing them to
electroporation and we exposing them to
a B so as far as we know so you can you
can measure gene expression changes in
the past when people started doing these
experiments that we're using other
plasmids or naked RNA or the Kath
language deliver as an mRNA or as a
plasmid and what we know is that
delivering as protein and modified guide
really decreases a lot of those effects
but there are some and then there's like
as we discussed earlier the AV has
effects on VHS PCs as well
thank you can we use the HS pcs as a
therapy for inflammation of
neurodegenerative disorder I think so I
think it were I think so and encouraging
people recently I don't remember was
there recent but I think yeah there's no
I think there's good evidence to think
that that would be possible
thank you and dr. Gomez asking about the
rap with this final question here how
can we make sure that the cells that we
save after re injection into patients
especially because these cells were in
vitro expanded
chuckling make sure that the cells are
saved are saved yes after reinjection
and so I mean see if I understand this
question correctly
so normally you know when you these
earlier trials will probably require
that you have a backup sample of the
patient cells that are modified to be
able to rescue in case you know the
cells that work I'm not sure that's
where the question is going but yeah so
you know the for for patient
specifically they'll probably a
requirement to have a backup of
unmodified cells that you can use in
case your therapy doesn't work
very good and if we didn't answer that
question correctly please feel free to
submit that question again Amon and
we'll try to answer your question more
correctly but I want to thank all of our
attendees who submitted their questions
we had a great Q&A session today but I
really want to thank dr. Gomez's bina
for her time today and her important
research we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsors stem cell
technologies for underwriting today's
educational webcast as a reminder to our
audience those questions we did
excuse me those questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during our on-demand period will be
addressed via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
now this webcast can be viewed on demand
and labyrinth will alert you via email
when it is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day